this is our new recruit leota de vaio  i've done a lot of notable things it's  super big if i told you anymore i'd have  to you know  adebayo is very green and is learning  this job on the go  we just gotta shut it  like  pull your jets jason bourne just be  ready to take off when we get back to  the car i got you adebayo continuously  has to prove herself what are your  actual qualifications i don't want to  say it out loud she's trying to navigate  who to be loyal to i just want to do  whatever job we're telling right from  wrong ain't advanced calculus it's  friendly oh yeah  [Music]  then i thought you said it was friendly  oh i thought you meant friendly to me  leota is the audience's point of view  you don't have to shoot people after her  to kill them right  [Music]